so I believe language teaching needs to  take place together with the culture of  that language and whenever we teach them  like linguistics patterns for instance  even like greetings okay the linguistics  forms are very simple but Japanese  people always bow so whenever we teach  some grammar patterns we also teach say  body language and also like whenever we  introduce honorific we have to introduce  the society I mean the hierarchical and  structure of the Japanese society we  need to introduce students the concept  of we have to show respect toward the  elderly so every linguistic aspect  involves a cultural understanding so  whenever possible we introduce culture  together with language also textbook has  so called culture nodes so each lesson  has cultural note to introduce one  aspect of the Japanese culture for  instance Japanese housing Japanese food  how to take off shoes something like  this